well the left will stop at nothing to
demonize law-abiding gun owners their
latest effort putting pro-gun
republicans in the same category
as one of the world's most evil men
osama bin laden
lots of people immediately noted that
the use of guns in that way is props and
the implicit threat that comes with them
has a
you know long not necessarily uh
great history among various movements
around the globe
osama bin laden for one liked to pose in
front of a bookshelf with a gun
prominently displayed
here now joe concha the hill media
opinion columnist and fox
news contributor chris hayes also
compared republicans to cuban
revolutionaries and gun owners of course
and to the irish republican army of
course terrorists so
we see this a lot but here we go with
another example
yeah comparing a sitting u.s
congresswoman to a terror leader
katie that was responsible for nearly
the deaths of 3 000 americans
it's a bold strategy katie let's see if
it works out for him but but here's why
you should never take
chris hayes seriously let me read you a
couple of his greatest hits
quote donald trump is objectively
pro-coveted
unquote in other words a city u.s
president is rooting for the deaths of
his own citizens what kind of person
with a national
platform like his says something like
that if you like unintentional comedy
he once said quote just remember when i
was a little kid i was strictly
forbidden from watching the dukes of
hazard by my mom
because of the flag on the car yep that
happened also hayes said quote
there will be gop congressional
candidates in 2022 whose campaign slogan
will be some sort of version of quote
storm the capital because you know not
every gop
lawmaker disowned that horrible riot
that day on january 6. it's ridiculous
he's also
declared that he was once uncomfortable
calling fallen soldiers
heroes he's the same guy who once asked
is the president united states working
for russia and pushed that
disinformation
for many years so yeah you don't even
need a new year's resolution katie
just don't take somebody like this who
makes statements like this seriously
it's it's
bad for your health yeah joe but when it
comes to you know the media and the
press and how they cover
gun ownership in america it's obvious to
me the way that chris hayes categorized
the congresswoman he just doesn't
understand american gun culture he
doesn't respect
the second amendment they don't do
anything to make sure that they're
accurate when it comes to terminology
that they use when they're
reporting on gun owners in america i
mean we always see these stories about
how they went out to some town to talk
to trump
trump uh voters and it's the same thing
with gun ownership in america it's like
they're these
zoo animals that they go to you know
explore and learn about
but they actually never reflect that in
their work
of course and think about where national
political media is located katie it's
either in washington
or new york primarily look at the way
those particular cities vote in in your
average election right so it's certainly
a bubble and a hive mentality but back
to hayes for a moment this is very
interesting
i'm old enough to remember 2018 i was
around for that
and there was a guy and you probably
remember this who's currently in the
congress right now actually his name is
conor lamb
and he was this democrat running in a
red district in pennsylvania
and lamb his first campaign ad showed
him shooting
an ak-15 with a narrator saying
in the background he still loves to
shoot you'll never guess
what msnbc primetime host didn't say a
word
about that wow a lawmaker featuring a
gun
boy where was the comparison to osama
bin laden or any terror leader that's
right it didn't happen
because there's a d next to conor lamb's
name so this isn't even
outraged by chris hayes that's misplaced
it's phony outrage
in order to serve up red meat to his
audience and again that's why we should
never take him seriously yeah i also
think it's dangerous though because you
have democrats not trying to classify a
whole swath of people they disagree with
as
terrorists and the media is more than
happy to follow along with that
narrative when it comes to
the right people that they want to
target in this case second amendment
uh supporters or gun owners
yeah it's one hell of a business model
right when you have 74 million people
that voted
for a particular candidate and you want
to go after uh that person
i guess that's fair game because that's
part of the contract but again to go
after his voters and use this broad
brush
that they're all x y and z in terms of
horrible people
uh yeah that's that's not going to get
you very far and then i'll leave you
with this final stack katie
84 of the american people believe that
the media bears the blame for dividing
this country that's a gallup poll that
was taken
just a couple of months ago and it's
statements like this from mr hayes that
underscored that completely
and totally by the way congrats on this
uh this week you're doing good so far
appreciate it thank you well thank you
for coming on to help me out i
appreciate it
talk to you soon take care